[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
youtube has demonetized almost all of my
recent videos so
if you're able please consider
supporting this channel by becoming a
patron at patreon.com
second thought
[Music]
the less you eat drink and buy books the
less you go to the theater the dance
hall the public house
the less you think love theorize sing
paint
fence etc the more you save the greater
becomes your treasure which neither
moths nor rust will devour
your capital the less you are the less
you express your own life
the more you have i.e the greater is
your alienated life
the greater is the store of your
estranged being everything which the
political economist takes from you in
life and in humanity he replaces for you
in money and in wealth
all passions and all activity must
therefore be submerged in avarice
the worker may only have enough for him
to want to live and may only want to
live in order to have that
these words penned by karl marx in 1844
are no less true today than they were
170 years ago and nowhere on earth do
they ring more true than in the united
states
as the wealthiest nation on earth the
u.s enjoys the privilege of looking down
on the rest of the world as quote less
successful
our people basking in the light of
glorious american exceptionalism
what we fail to realize is that our
concept of success is not only narrow
and short-sighted but also fundamentally
opposed to human flourishing
our population as a whole may enjoy more
wealth than some of our peer nations but
at what cost
our waking hours are consumed by work
our life expectancy is on the decline
we rate poorly in metrics like happiness
and job satisfaction
and those of us in the workforce today
will never achieve the financial
stability of our parents generation
in this episode we're going to attempt
to divorce the notion of success from
the dogged pursuit of the accumulation
of capital
let's start with the core belief that
animates many american workers
the idea of the american dream a sort of
national ethos the philosophy of the
american dream can be summed up
something like this
everyone has the opportunity for
prosperity and success regardless of
their background and based solely upon
their ability or achievement
it's very much a pull yourself up by
your bootstraps mentality
a phrase which is also very common in
american life the idea that one should
be able to succeed without any external
help
solely through one's own force of will
and hard work this notion is of course
absurd
and is made even more ridiculous by the
fact that the phrase has been adopted by
so many in a manner completely opposite
to its original meaning
to pull yourself up by your own
bootstraps is obviously impossible
and that was the original meaning of the
phrase to attempt something that is
completely absurd
of course in america nothing is
impossible so we refitted the expression
to better suit our dogmatic obsession
with self-reliance
america is an interesting case study
because unlike many other countries when
settlers first arrived here there seemed
to be an endless expanse of land to
explore and claim
this frontier lifestyle gave birth to
the restless nature of the american
dream
one governor noted in 1774 that the
americans forever
imagine the lands further off are still
better than those upon which they are
already settled he added that if they
attained paradise
they would move on if they heard of a
better place farther west this sums up
the american relationship to work pretty
well
what we have is never enough we need to
accumulate more and more wealth never
satisfied ever striving
over the last couple centuries the
american dream has evolved into what we
see today
work hard save money send your kids to
college so they can live a better life
than you did retire to florida
in a lot of ways this is a noble goal
the desire for your children to live a
better life than you did is what we
should expect of ourselves
but more recently over the past 50 years
or so the benefits of hard work have
been stripped away
and the things older generations took
for granted have all but disappeared
jobs are harder to find and pay far less
money than our parents were paid for
comparable positions
pension plans and retirement benefits
are rarely offered these days
we have some of the worst vacation and
parental leave options in the world
much of the economy has shifted to gig
work which doesn't have to provide
health insurance or any other benefits
and domestic and global perception of
the us is on a decidedly downward
trajectory
but don't just take my word for it let's
look at a few statistics
back in the 1960s only 20 percent of
american mothers worked
this was partly due to the perceived
role of the mother as the primary
homemaker and caretaker
but it was also largely because most
households only needed one source of
income to provide a financially stable
and upwardly mobile life
today 70 percent of american children
live in households where both parents
are employed
most families simply can't get by on a
single source of income
at least 134 countries have laws that
cap the maximum length of the work week
the u.s does not in the united states
almost 86
of men and over 66 percent of women work
more than 40 hours per week
you've probably heard that japanese
workers are some of the most overworked
in the world
the average american works 137 more
hours per year than the average japanese
worker
we work 260 more hours than the british
we work
499 more hours than the french according
to the bureau of labor statistics
productivity of the average american
worker has increased by 400
since 1950. if we're producing value at
four times the previous rate
that would mean we could earn a
comparable living to our grandparents in
one quarter of the work hours right
obviously that's not the case we're
working longer hours at a drastically
increased rate of productivity but we
don't benefit from that labor
well at least we're rewarded with
generous vacation and parental leave
oh wait no we have the worst rankings in
the developed world
and worse rankings than many third world
countries among 41 studied nations the
u.s ranks dead last in terms of paid
parental leave
we are the only nation out of those 41
that does not mandate some amount of
paid parental leave
for comparison the smallest amount of
paid leave required by the remaining 40
nations in the study is about 2 months
2 months of paid leave in the u.s is
unfathomable
in 34 of the 41 countries some of the
leave is allocated for new fathers
there's a reason we only ever hear the
phrase maternity leave in the u.s
and that's because new fathers are never
eligible for leave in order to spend
time with their child
some countries that rank higher than the
u.s include mexico greece croatia
even our fellow workaholic japan estonia
offers 86 weeks of paid parental leave
again the united states offers nothing
there are
zero industrialized nations on earth
that don't have a mandatory option for
paid parental leave
except the us vacation and sick time is
a similar story
we don't have a federal law requiring
paid sick days nor do we have a law
mandating paid annual leave
once again making us the only
industrialized nation not to do so
take a look at this graph you might
notice there's a bar missing
that would be the united states not
mandating any paid leave whatsoever
it's especially depressing when you
realize that a mcdonald's employee in
norway gets more vacation time than just
about any american worker regardless of
field or salary
meanwhile in the united states we abuse
our low paid workers and lambast them
for being lazy and not finding a better
job
it's no wonder that our citizens
consistently rank poorly for happiness
and job satisfaction
they're being worked to death are not
offered any benefits get no time off and
on top of that are abused for trying to
earn a living
what's perhaps more disappointing than
wealthy older people deriding low-paid
workers is other workers in precarious
positions doing the same
for example take gig economy workers
while some of them are fully aware that
their occupation is based on their own
exploitation
there's a disappointing subset of people
who buy into the notion of quote hustle
culture
you'll see these people make
inspirational instagram posts posting
images of jeff bezos
using hashtags like rise and grind and
going on about how the key to success is
to work all day
every day until it pays off here's the
thing for these people
it will never pay off deifying rich
people who accumulated their wealth by
exploiting others or inheriting vast
sums of money doesn't make you smart
it means you've bought their propaganda
if you drive 15 hours a day for uber you
might make a bit more money
but you don't have any opportunity for
advancement you're not suddenly going to
get health insurance or vacation
time because you're working hard you're
a piece of equipment to them
you drive the car you make them money
that's all you're worth to uber
but this toxic idea that we need to give
up hours days
years of our lives as a sort of
sacrifice to appease the gods of success
is not only misguided it's actively
throwing away your life
hustle culture destroys your work-life
balance and those who engage in it see
themselves as morally superior to people
working traditional jobs for a wage
these sorts of false divisions among the
working class are exactly what the
ruling class wants
the same is true of the false division
between the working class and the
so-called middle class
it's a meaningless distinction designed
solely to make more comfortable workers
feel superior to their lower paid
counterparts and therefore at odds with
their own best interests
if you feel superior to others or see
yourself more like the billionaires than
your fellow workers you'll never
organize against your oppressors because
you believe you might one day become
part of this upper echelon
if you just work a few more hours per
week surely you'll be rewarded and gain
entrance into their elite club
america's cult of overwork destroys our
collective imagination
it removes every possible motivation
beyond the desire for the accumulation
of more wealth
to many americans there is nothing but
work and the possibility of eventual
reward
work is the only thing that matters but
there is so much more to life than what
capitalism has conditioned us to pursue
if we worked fewer hours we could take
time to spend with family and friends
we could learn that hobby we've been
putting off for years we could write
novels produce art
create things that enrich the lives of
others on a fundamental human level
we could take time to just exist when
was the last time you just took a day to
relax and you didn't feel guilty about
it
we are so conditioned to believe that we
should always be working that even when
we're not working it's all we can think
about
the american dream the obsession that
anyone can quote make it if they work
hard enough
is thoroughly tangled up with the notion
of american exceptionalism
we think it's because we work so hard
that we are exceptional
and you know what we are exceptional
we're the most overworked population on
the planet
our standard of living is going down our
life expectancy is going down
we don't get vacation days sick days or
time to spend with our newborn children
we're increasingly unhappy our economy
is teetering on the brink of the worst
financial crisis in modern history
we can't protect ourselves from a
pandemic that everyone else handled
because we're so conditioned to believe
that we always need to be working
and somehow we still believe that the
american dream is a reality
so yes we are exceptional but we are
exceptional in all the wrong ways
if we don't dismantle the oppressive
structures that enable this culture of
overwork
this is the only form of american
exceptionalism that will ever exist
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is
supported by my patrons on patreon
this type of video while very important
is something that sponsors won't touch
in order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running i rely on adsense
revenue
sponsors and donations from generous
viewers by producing explicitly
anti-capitalist content
i lose out on both sponsors and adsense
if you enjoy the kind of videos i'm
producing and you're able to chip in
even a dollar a month
i would greatly appreciate the support
you can find my patreon page at
patreon.com
second thought every tier comes with
discord benefits for our new and growing
discord server
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching
and i'll see you next week
you